is it because you're part of the Hamas
caucus and I'm Jewish all right no it's
cuz you're a transp thank you one good
person who's out there fighting this
stuff is haa raic you know her better
she's better known as Libs of Tik tock
on Twitter and she just does an absolute
uh great job she has confronted some of
the people from our Hamas caucus uh on
the floors of the house many times here
she is in the last day or two uh going
after AOC and trying to get her to
condemn Hamas or anything and and just
like we've shown you these videos
from ilhan Omar we've shown you these
videos from Rashida T they seem
incapable of condemning people who
literally put children into Ovens that
seems a bridge too far for these people
to take a look hey can I grab a photo
with you hi
thanks oh hi so when you told me you
never wanted to share a space with me I
never want to share space with you thank
you is it cuz you're part of the Hamas
caucus and I'm Jewish all right no it's
cuz you're
thank you oh okay so go so oh are you
heading to Hamas Caucus
meeting when's the next one you know
there are Americans being held
hostage do you
care do you care that Hamas is holding
Americans
hostage what do you say to the families
of Americans who are currently being
held hostage by
Hamas does the Hamas caucus have a
statement about
it
I is really great you know that's not
easy to do to get in somebody's face
like it looks like it could be fun or
silly but like it's not the easiest
thing to do I've been around these
people and security and you don't know
what they're going to do to you so
that's just a beautiful moment but
notice AOC again she just simply cannot
condemn these people and she was so
excited to take the picture at first and
then she realized oh oh uh oh uhoh it's
her and then what is what is her answer
why doesn't she like her because she's
transphobic which means that haa has an
irrational fear of trans people
no that is not true and the word much
like islamophobic is completely
ridiculous it's not about an irrational
fear it in this case is more about she
doesn't want little boys wangs cut off
so that they can pretend that they're
girls in the name of Tolerance and
diversity all right so AOC and and by
the way as you know aocc has no
knowledge of of the history or anything
else and the revolution will eat her the
way the revolution is eating Bernie
Sanders who's largely IR irrelevant
Hallelujah the the revolution will
eventually eat AOC so there is a silver
lining to all of this guys
St